Mount Charleston received a record
amount of snow this season but all that
snow needs a place to go as temps soar
especially today Victoria Saha reports
on the difficulty
as Valley residents deal with
temperatures in the 90s the residents up
here in Mount Charleston are dealing
with this
flooding on private roads as the snow
starts to melt in but it's only going to
get worse Springtime in the canyons full
of love the mountains full of love and
full of snow you can't really have a
good schedule up here you know Mother
Nature has its own schedule Jimmy
Alderson is known as Mount Charleston
Mountain Man to his neighbors here
sitting on the side of a mountain he
sings about his Mountain love but as
beautiful as it may be there's a
downfall after winter all that snow up
there on the top has to uh has to melt
off and come down the reason more than
260 inches of snow on the mountains from
just this season higher up in the
mountain you can see that the snow is
really starting to melt down causing
streams to form in the roads and it's
making it really difficult for residents
to go up to their house it gets pretty
bad making for a very bumpy ride as I'm
coming up here I have to make sure I
keep my momentum this is going to become
a giant ditch right through here
where it goes is not necessarily
something that we direct or try to push
Andrew Mitchell with the forestry
service says the snow melt could be
anywhere on the mountain Louisville pass
and the wheeler pass OHV Trail I've been
both been washed out and that's the kind
of the situations that we could probably
experience more of but as temperatures
dip back down this snow that is melting
will turn into ice causing another worry
snow drift
and icy Trails as for mountain man he's
bracing himself for the worst that's Yet
to Come living here neat the Clear Blue
Sky sitting on the side of the mountain